Previously on startup.
I started a company called [inaudible], which is a platform to share 6.1 second
would have been videos. I have a rich nemesis called Aria who embarrassed me in
a game of chess. I started to work on not fine. And then suddenly Aria launched
unrefined before us allowing people to share 5.9 second videos.
Boy.
You got to launch today.
We've got to make sure we launch before we might realize.
Wait, who is this?
Somebody told me they give this to you guys.
Thank you for applying to the university of Waterloo.
BRB. Is this?
Yup. Where are you? I'm on PTO. Chillin in LA PTO.
We don't have any PTO stops. Don't have videos.
I can't afford that on your contract. You said unlimited PTO, all startups data.
We don't actually have PTLs would just say that. And also,
who was this person in my living room. Oh, that's Genevieve.
She's my substitute for the day. What? Substitute.
You're not a great school teacher.
You can't just have substitutes in the middle of a launch and your Ellie,
Ellie need you.
You can't just bring some random 18 year old developed a substitute.
Hi, uh, you must be Genevieve. You know, we're very happy to have you here.
And uh, yeah.
[Inaudible]
tabs or spaces.
Tom's my vent. Turns them into four spaces,
react or angular react hands down
Macintosh or of course Mac or granny Smith.
Uh.
Then I guess granny Smith, honey crisp apples are the only Apple machines.
I didn't know it was it anyways?
What's your expertise? Well,
I'm a data engineer by trade so I can set up your whole data infrastructure from
logging to warehousing. And how would you do that? Well,
first I develop a custom logging agent that delivers all of that logs to capita,
delivering both into S3 for long-term cold storage and Redshift.
So drummer can use SQL to pull his data since he doesn't actually know how to
code. I know I'm a cold. Sure. Uh, then to scale,
we'll have to store these data on clusters.
So I'll use spark to run all the jobs we need,
but I doubt we'll need that since you guys have no users, but we will.
I mean, we are deleting 6.1 second. Flipping video.
Yeah.
All right team.
So it's important to let our new members feel like part of the team.
So we're going to do a quick ice breaker, two truths and one lie.
So who wants to go first? Okay, let's go. Uh,
I, uh, I got this. So, um, first one, two plus two equals four.
Oh my God is Waterloo is even Harvard
and Microsoft is a reputable tech company.
All right. Cool. Awesome. Okay. So yeah.
Um, my super hot girlfriend,
one university metal before she got hired at Google,
she's a part-time model and she's the one who came up with Teslas before Elon
Musk, but lost it because of a patent lawsuit.
So.
As a CEO of the company, you know, my job isn't to be the best at everything.
I mean, even though I probably am my job as a CEO is to empower all my
employees to reach their maximum potential.
And you know how synergy two plus two equals five
and you know how we get synergy pair programming. Okay. Go last question
on that one. No, not that one. Yeah. Great news RD.
No, that's not how you spell it. It's you
again? Let me just do it. Honestly.
John code is pretty terrible. I don't know what they taught them in Microsoft,
but it clearly isn't working. I'm pretty much at God at coding. You know,
I write high performance code.
That's why I always leave only one character for my bearable names so that,
you know, the compiler reads it faster.
Joan was code is unreadable.
Are you done with the database migration? Nah, I'll get to that.
After I finished this thing, I kind of need it. I'm black by it.
What is this thing that you're finishing?
I'm reading this privacy policy thing that Microsoft sent me.
It looks really important. Oh, another one, huh? I guess I'll read that one.
Next.
John is very diligent.
Man. I hate merge conflicts.
Like I never know what to do with them so complicated,
but I recently learned something on the kid that if you type this command,
it just fixes everything for you and pushes your code. It's amazing.
So what do you think about Genevieve? Oh, she's cool. I guess. I mean, yeah,
she's not as pretty as my really hot girlfriend,
but I think she can have some potential distributors out who the real boss is
here. So you finished that data migration yet?
Um, it's still migrating.
So what are we doing?
I recently read a book for pickup artists called the game and I've been doing
rejection challenges to build up my confidence.
I tried nuggets on me and didn't really get me anywhere.
So I'm trying to assert dominance in the workplace,
sir. Are you like in a college or something?
No, I dropped out after my first semester.
It wasn't really worth it now I just do freelance stuff.
Oh yeah. I, I feel, yeah, I never went to college either.
I applied to Harvard and they said I was a little bit too experienced. You know,
my girlfriends dated a lot of coders in the past,
but she says I've got the sexiest helper functions that she's ever seen.
I do some contract work too. You know, Airbnb, Uber,
you might've heard of them.
I got paid a million dollars each to scale their architecture.
Oh yeah. That's cool. Of course. I know. You're a BNB. Send me an I,
our first company got acquired by them.
No. What was your startup?
Oh, it was really nothing. Just some big data analytics platform.
It was really just for fun, you know, for 30 mil.
Oh mother.
Finally. Oh, you fixed the bug? No, I meant finally,
this girl finally messaged me back. You'll check her out. Is she pretty?
Wow. Wait, why does she think you're gay?
Wait the helmet. Don't we? My messages, by the way,
are you done with the data migration yet? Okay.
So they keep talking about this data migration thing.
I don't know what a data migration is and it's kind of too late to ask
now, do you know what a data migration is?
Are you on Tinder? No, no, no, no. That's not mine.
I have a girlfriend. I swear. It's not mine. I don't know what that is.
Wow. We did it. Good job guys. Good job. Nice.
Alright. Yeah, let's launch it.
Cool. Can you also put the dashboard? All right.
All we gotta do now is your users.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
What's popping guys. Thank you so much for watching this episode.
I hope you enjoyed it. If you did. Don't forget to like and subscribe.
I know it's been like two months as an episode, but I'm back at it.
So every month we will post another new start-up episode.
The next one will be on July 1st. Now I have an announcement to make,
we have new merge. Let me show you a couple.
So this one is a very, very comfortable sweatshirt a year.
And then also like the American apparel stamp of hoodie.
Yeah.
And then of course, if you want to show some cleavage,
we got a v-neck t-shirt a year, so yeah.
Yeah. So all of these will be available on Java swiped.com.
Right when I post this video. So yeah, don't forget to check it out.
It's pretty dope. Uh, yeah,
if you want to represent online or support my channel,
then definitely get one of these apparels. So yeah. Thank you so much.
[Inaudible].